>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
FOR MORE ON THE GUN DEBATE WE
BRING YOU THE FIRST PART OF A
THREE-PART SERIES WITH JOHN
OLIVER.
>> YESTERDAY, AMERICANS WATCHED
IN SHOCK AS EVEN WATERED DOWN
GUN LEGISLATION DIE ON THE FLOOR
OF THE SENATE.
BUT THAT IS EXACTLY WHERE IT
BELONGS, ACCORDING TO GUN
LOBBYIST OF THE VIRGINIA
CITIZENS DEFENSE LEAGUE.
>> THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
SACROSANCT.
>> YOU HOLD THUP SIGN WHENEVER I
MAKE A SUGGESTION THAT YOU THINK
IS INFRINGING UPON YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTSES, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> ASSAULT WEAPON BAN.
BOOM, THERE IT IS.
INCREASED BACKGROUND CHECKS.
REALLY?
>> YES.
>> JUST FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS?
>> WE DON'T DO BACKGROUND CHECKS
FOR THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
>> OKAY, SO LET'S JUST TRY THIS
ONE, NICE AND EASY.
>> SURE.
>> A MANDATORY ONE-HOUR WAITING
PERIOD IF YOU BUY A GUN.
>> WHY-- WHY-- ( BLEEP ).
>> UNLESS I CAN SEE A REASON.
NO, I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING
THEY SUPPORT BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY, NONE OF IT WORKS.
>> EXACTLY, GUN CONTROL DOES NOT
WORK.
WHAT IF HYPOTHETICALLY SPEAKING,
GUN CONTROL COULD WORK-- WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IT CAN'T SO WE KNOW IT
WON'T SO THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM,
BUT WHAT IF IT DID.
>> WHEN WAS THAT?
>> AUSTRALIA.
YES, AUSTRALIA INSPECT IN 1996,
A CONSERVATIVE PRIME MINISTER
JOHN HOWARD INSTITUTED SWEEPING
GUN CONTROL LAWS FOLLOWING A
MASS SHOOTING THAT SHOCKED THE
NATION.
SO SHOULD WE BE LEARNING FROM
THIS EFFECTIVE EXAMPLE?
OF COURSE NOT.
>> I GUESS IF WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO PLANET X. AND SAY IT'S NOT
UNITED STATES, SOME OTHER
PLANET, DIFFERENT PEOPLE,
DIFFERENT EVERYTHING, I DON'T
KNOW, YEAH, YOU KNOW, BUT IN THE
REAL WORLD WITH HUMAN BEINGS
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK, AND GUN
CONTROL ISN'T GOING TO WORK.
>> UNFORTUNATELY NOT TONAL IS
AUSTRALIA ACTUALLY IN THE REAL
WORLD.
EVEN THEIR ANINALS CAN HOIST A
WEAPON.
WHO IS RIGHT ABOUT GUN CONTROL?
THERE WAS ONLY ONE WAY TO FIND
OUT.
CONFRONT THE MAN RESPONSIBLE.
MR. PRIME MINISTER, LET'S BEGIN
IN THE FORMAL AUSTRALIAN WAY--
G-DAY.
>> HOW DO YOU DO.
>> OBVIOUSLY, GUN CONTROL
DOESN'T WORK.
IT CAN'T WORK.
IT WILL NEVER WORK.
SO WOW WAS YOUR SCHEME A
FAILURE?
>> WELL, MY SCHEME WAS NOT A
FAILURE.
WE HAD A MASSACRE AT PORT ARTHUR
17 YEARS AGO, AND THERE HAVE
BEEN NONE SINCE.
>> ZERO GUN MASS CERS.
HOLD ON.
DID GUN CONTROL ACTUALLY WORK?
>> IT STOPPED ONE THING.
THAT COULD ALSO BE A STATISTICAL
ANOMALY.
>> YEAH, IT WAS JUST MASS
SHOOTINGS DISAPPEARED.
>> THERE WERE SO FEW OF THEM,
WHOOP-DEE-DO.
>> WHOOP-DEE-DO?
>> YES THEIR SHOOTINGS ARE RARE
ANYHOW.
>> EXACTLY, THEY PROBABLY BARELY
HAD A MASSACRE BEFORE 1996.
>> THERE WERE ABOUT 13 IN THE
PREVIOUS 18 YEARS.
IN THE 18 YEARS BEFORE PORT
ARTHUR, THERE WERE 13 MASS
SHOOTINGS.
ALMOST ONE A YEAR.
>> I WAS UNAWARE THEY HAD THAT
MANY.
MASS BEING, WHAT, MORE THAN TWO
PEOPLE AT A TIME?
>> MORE THAN FOUR.
>> MORE THAN FOUR, OKAY.
>> WHOOP-DEE-DO.
>> PERHAPS THERE WERE OFFER
NON-WHOOP-DEE-DO SIDE EFFECTS.
>> THE HOMICIDE RATE INVOLVING
THE USE OF GUNS HAS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY FACTORS OF UP
TO 50% AND 60%, AND THE
INCIDENCE OF YOUTH SUICIDES
INVOLVING GUNS HAS DECLINED
DRAMATICALLY.
>> WHOOP-DEE-( BLEEP )-DO.
SUICIDE WITH GUNS WENT DOWN,
ZERO MASS SHOOTINGS.
>> AUSTRALIA STILL HAS MURDER
RATES AND ROBBERIES LAST I
CHECKED.
>> UNLESS YOU CAN GET RID OF
100% OF CRIME, IT'S NOT WORTH
DOING AT ALL?
>> PUT IT THIS WAY, IT'S ILLEGAL
TO HAVE CRACK COCAINE ANYWHERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
DO YOU THINK IF SOMEBODY REALLY
WANTS IT THEY CAN GET THEIR
HANDS ON CRACK COCAINE IN
AMERICA?
>> SO UNLESS WE CAN COMPLETELY
GET RID OF DRUGS, THERE'S NO
POINT IN HAVING DRUG LAWS AT
ALL.
( APPLAUSE )
>> LET ME THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
MINUTE.
WELL, I GUESS, EFFECTIVELY IT
DOESN'T WORK.
>> YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH PHILLIP.
EVEN HIS LOGIC IS BULLETPROOF.
>> WELL, LET ME PUT IT TO YOU
THIS WAY.
THERE ARE MORE DROWN IN
BACKYARDS WHERE THEY HAVE POOLS.
IF THERE ARE NO POOLS THEY DON'T
HAVE A DROWNING IN THE BACKYARD.
THE U.S. HAS A VERY HIGH NUMBER
OF GUNS.
THEREFORE, THERE IS GOING TO BE
MORE CHANCES FOR SOMEBODY TO BE
KILLED WITH A GUN.
>> RIGHT.
RIGHT.
THAT'S MY POINT.
THE SENATE MIGHT THINK LIVING IN
A SOCIETY WITH DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED GUN VIOLENCE IS EYE
WHO-DEE-DO, AND PEOPLE IN
AUSTRALIA COULDN'T AGREE WITH
HIM MORE.
>> WHOOP-DEE-DO.
>> WHOOP-DEE-DO, MATE.
>> WHOOP-DEE-DO, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
>> WHOOP-DEE-( BLEEP )-DO!
>> Jon: WE'LL BE RIGHT